around the world most people know what
happened in Hiroshima but even though
the horrific nuclear bomb was dropped
here almost 78 years ago visiting for
the first time as a deeply moving
experience
and it's humbling to meet survivors like
90 year old Sade kazioka both her
parents died she showed me a picture
drawn from her Recollections showing the
last moments of her badly burned father
and she recalled what happened at 8 15
in the morning on the 6th of August
1945.
when I finished my chores in the morning
I saw this beautiful bright light in
front of my eyes it looked like the
first Sunrise of the year a beautiful
orange light and while I was starting to
wonder what it was the front window
exploded I was hit by Broken Glass and
pushed towards the wall by the power of
the blast I didn't understand what had
happened that's how it all started
up to 135 000 people died in this city
for the 60 to 80 000 were killed when a
second bomb was dropped three days later
on Nagasaki
in 1945 toshiko Tanaka who lost both of
her parents and many other family
members was just six years old she has
this message for the G7
I want them to really pay attention to
what happens when you use a nuclear
weapon there is a war in Ukraine now and
this Summit should not be a place where
you make military preparations in
Hiroshima we have experienced a nuclear
bomb firsthand this meeting should be a
place where they find a way towards
peace
with them and to and to listen to Daniel
hochstra is the acting director of the
international campaign to abolish
nuclear weapons which won the Nobel
Peace Prize five years ago the G7 Summit
is taking a place in the context of a
brutal invasion of Ukraine by Russia
where nuclear threats are kind of used
as nuclear blackmail uh in that in that
context they say that the risks of the
use of nuclear weapons are the highest
they've been since the 1980s probably so
what we really need to see from the G7
leaders is is leadership the survivors
all now elderly and in a matter of years
what happened here one of the worst
things mankind has ever suffered will
pass beyond living memory it will not
though and must not ever be forgotten
the world owes it to this place and its
people that the memory is never
extinguished James Bays Al Jazeera
Hiroshima
[Applause]